وقد اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
فتاه فلسطينيه برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في بلد حواره جنوب ونابس وكان
الهلال الاحمر والفلسطيني قضى علينا ان
القوات الاسرائيليه اطلقت النار على فتاه
فلسطينيه في دوار الزيتونه عنابوس بدعوه
للشبه في تنفيذها عمليه طعن ضد مستوطن
اصيب بجروح خفيفه
منها مراسله الجزيره جيفا
القديمه جيفارا والمحلات مغلقه وان هناك
شلل ربما الان في الحياه العامه في نابلس
بعد تشييع جنازه الشهداء الثلاثه متى سيتم
تشييع ايضا الفتاه
بالفعل يعني نحن نتواجد في داخل ازقه
البلده القديمه بالطبع كل شيء مغلق بسبب
الاضراب الشامل الذي اعلنت عنه القوى
الوطنيه والاسلاميه بعد الاعلان عن اغتيال
الشهداء الثلاثه هذه الطريق عبد الصمد
تؤدي الى حاره الياسمين حيث يوجد المنزل
الذي دمرته قوات الاحتلال واطلقت عليه عده
صواريختيال الشهداء الثلاثه وهم معاذ
المصري حسن قطاطني وابراهيم جوري جبر طبعا
تم اغتيالهم في داخل المنزل الذي حوصل
لاكثر من ساعتين وكانت السنه الدخان
تتصاعد في ذلك الوقت بالطبع نحن لم نستطيع
الدخول اكثر من ذلك لان الاجهزه المختصه
قامت باغلاق المنطقه بالكامل خشيه من
انفجار اي جسم موجود في داخل المنزل سواء
كان الشهداء قد قاموا بتفخيخ المنزل قبل
دخول قوات الاحتلال وهذا ما اكدته عدد من
مصادر مقربه من المقاومه الفلسطينيه او ان
كان جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد تركوا اي
معدات خاصه لهم لتتبع المزيد من المقاومين
الفلسطينيين او لتفجير المزيد من المنازل
او حتى متفجرات ومنفخخات بالطبع الجنازه
شارك بها الالاف راينا اعلام حركه حماس
التي ينتمي اليها الشهداء الثلاث رايناها
ترفرف هنا في وسط مدينه نابلس لم يكن هناك
اي احتكاكات بل كان هناك وحده حال بين
الفلسطينيين والتاكيد على ان الشهداء
الذين يسقطونهم شهداء يسقطون من اجل تحرير
الارض الفلسطينيه وكانت كتائب عز الدين
القسام الجناح المسلح لحركه حماس قد اكدت
ان الشهداء الثلاثه هم وانهم قاموا بتنفيذ
عمليه الحمراء قبل زهاء الشهر في خضام شهر
رمضان المبارك بعد الاعتداء على المعتكفين
والحرائر في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك
بالطبع كل الفصائل مع الشهداء الثلاثه
وايضا اكدت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه ان
الاحتلال وحده وحكومه الاحتلال تتحمل
مسؤوليات تبعات هذه العمليه التي تاتي بعد
اقل من 48 ساعه ايضا على
استشهاد الاسير الشيخ خضر عدنان الذي اضرب
عن الطعام لاكثر من 86 يوما واستشهد داخل
سجون الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولكن بالطبع
ايضا منطقه حوار جنوب نابلس تشهد ايضا
توتر كبير في هذه الاثناء بعد الاعلان عن
استشهاد الشابه الفلسطينيه ايمان زياد
عوده والبالغه من العمر 26 عاما بعد ان
اطلق عليها جنود الاحتلال
الرصاصه اصابتها في الصدر بزعم انها حاولت
طعن احد الجنود عندما
وهو مفرق في داخل شرح حواره الرئيسي الذي
كان يعني من اهم المعالم خلال الاشهر
الماضيه الاعتداءات
المستوطنين ولكن الفلسطينيين يفندون روايه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لانه كيف يمكن للسيده
ان تحاول طعن جندي يتواجد بين عشرات من
الجنود المدججين بالاسلحه بالطبع الان
الشهيده تم نقلها هنا الى مستشفى رفيديا
في مدينه نابلس وسيتم نقلها بعد ذلك
لتشريعها في بلده حواره اذا الاوضاع تتوتر
شيئا فشيئا نتحدث عن اربعه شهداء في اقل
من ساعتين عن 108 الشهداء في خلال خمسه
اشهر اي منذ بدايه هذا العام حتى هذا
اليوم
من نابلس